come on
one piece is an assembly line of super
powered characters after some time it's
no longer possible to be awestruck every
time a character puts on a show for us
or gets a ridiculous power upgrade
however every now and then there comes a
moment when a demonstration of power by
a character becomes much more than the
standard spectacle sometimes it displays
the characters immense growth over a
period of time at other times it's a
visualization of their determination to
achieve what they've set out to do many
times it's a very effective warning to
their rivals that they're not to be
taken lightly it's these backstories and
emotions that give these power
demonstrations gravity and staying power
keeping them in our memories for a long
time so today we're counting down the
top 10 showcases of power in one piece
we'll also see how each of these moments
contributes to the specific story
they're set in and to the development of
the characters involved let's get
started
[Music]
at number 10 we have the surgeon of
death himself trafalgar law cutting both
virgo and punk hazard into two neat
halves
[Music]
this scene shows just how terrifying and
mysterious law's abilities are for one
he's able to cut down virgo while the
latter's body is entirely clad in black
armament haki this type of haki as you
may already know hardens the user's body
turning it into an indestructible armor
that can't easily be damaged but lorna
only splits the haki protected virgo
into two he slices apart the entire
island dealing a body blow to his arch
nemesis doffy and he does this all
seemingly without using any armament
haki himself this scene perfectly
captures the silent menace of law's
mysterious power making the captain of
the heart pirates an a-class threat for
the rest of the series
[Music]
me
[Music]
next up is another man of few words but
incredible power
presenting former marine admiral aokiji
as he freezes the ocean with the power
of his ice age the action takes place in
the foxy arc which is more of a
recreational arc and a bit of a
diversion from the main story but
aokiji's presence marks an important
moment in luffy and the gang's journey
to notoriety his confrontation of the
straw hat shows that naval headquarters
in the world government have started to
take notice of the rabble-rousing
rookies and the threat that they might
one day present it also shows that the
admiral is a man of great foresight
despite appearing to be lazy on the
surface
laid back and non-threatening it doesn't
matter that aokiji uses his devil fruit
powers for good rather than combat in
this scene him defeating the straw hats
in his freezing of the sea shows just
how compelling his ice abilities are the
full might of which we see much later in
his fight against whitebeard in the
battle of marineford
at number eight we have blackbeard and
his disturbing power
in his clash with former crewmate ace
audiences are treated to two widely
contrasting powers one that's red hot
and full of light and another that's
dark and pure evil on blackbeard's
command an entire village is engulfed by
a mysterious black shadow until there's
nothing left it's as if the village fell
into an abyss and disappeared leaving
nothing in its way this clash is
significant because it serves as the
catalyst for the crucial marine food war
but it's also a showcase of blackbeard's
terrifying abilities which as he admits
himself are the most evil amongst the
devil fruit powers and we agree that his
scheme betrayal against his crew and
committed murder to acquire this power
shows how despicable he really is that
he chooses to target a village of
innocent people rather than his opponent
in testimony shows how low he can stoop
when it comes to one piece villains and
there are plenty of them perhaps none
are as hateful as blackbeard
moving on we have shanks who makes an
entrance every time he's on the screen
[Music]
the red-haired pirate impressed us when
he saved a young luffy from a sea
monster early in the series he caught
her eye again when he stepped in to
decisively end the battle of marineford
without raising a finger but it's his
appearance on whitebeard ships that
makes the cut at number seven because
the scene perfectly captures his silent
power and strong will marco's right to
warn the weaker members of the
whitebeard pirates to get back because
they can't handle shanks one piece
discussion forums are full of statements
of how shanks is one of the most if not
the most proficient users of haki and
it's clear to see why shanks's
conqueror's haki is so strong that even
when he's trying to suppress it it
manages to knock out a good number of
whitebeard's crew and damage his ship
we've just had these tiny glimpses of
the yonko's power and as the story
progresses we can't wait to see what
he's truly capable of
[Music]
you've got to be faster than light to
catch up to our next contender coming in
at number six is kizaru treating the
supernovas like a bunch of rowdy kids
who need a lesson in good behavior the
sabaodi arc is kizaru's arc considering
how much trouble he causes the notorious
gang of rookie pirates hell he even
manages to force the straw hats to take
a two-year sabbatical but it's his
dismantling of ex-drake basil hawkins
scratchman arpu and yuruj that opens her
eyes to what a big threat the marine
admiral really is the four pirates are
in no way weaklings but kizaru makes
them look toothless and incompetent if
there's ever been a one-sided fight then
this is it the superfast marine never
gives even one of the four pirates a
chance to land a hit on him however he
lands one fade to blow after another
without much effort at all the half
smile on his face makes it look like
he's come to a party rather than to
apprehend a gang of dangerous outlaws
[Music]
but speaking of showcases of power how
about i help you showcase your power
during shopping this is where the
sponsors of this video slick deals comes
in slick deals is the largest and most
trusted deal sharing company out there
thanks to their service people have
saved thousands of dollars in their hunt
for the best deals out there by
installing the slick deals browser
extension you can get the best prices
and discounts when you shop online it
allows you to compare sites with one
another in your hand to get the perfect
deal say goodbye to searching for
coupons or cashback points too slick
deals has that part down too and the
extension openly applies the latest
coupon codes i was looking for a pair of
wireless earbuds to watch anime on the
go and i found these amazing earbuds at
a huge discount the best part about
sleek deals is that it also features an
always active ever growing community
with over 12 million users sharing their
information you can easily get the best
deals available in real time get the
best prices for your gaming accessories
appliances and such at your fingertips
by downloading the extension through
this link in the description
it's another one versus many fights at
number five only it's way way bigger
luffy unleashing his conquerors haki on
a hundred thousand fish men and knocking
out half of them is a spectacle that
stood the test of time and he does it
without any preparation or effort
despite the straw hat captain's numerous
power-ups since then this haki moment
stands out as the most memorable
demonstration of luffy's growth on his
journey to become the pirate king it's
also proof of how far he's come since
the previously mentioned two years he
was forced to be away from his crew
since the fishman island incident luffy
has used haki countless times against
much more powerful opponents and has
come out tops each time but his
demonstration of determination and power
against the fishman pirates which left
even their captain holy jones speechless
remains unforgettable now that's how you
even the odds for your team when the
numbers are against you oh
[Music]
me
at number four we have kaido taking down
luffy in one shot
the action is heating up in the wano arc
and we can't wait for the final showdown
between these two adversaries but from
what we've seen so far kaido might just
be the wall that luffy fails to scale
despite the latter's obvious talent of
turning the tide of any fighter putting
off victory from the jaws of defeat
kaido seems much too strong an opponent
for the captain of the straw hats so it
looks like an unequal fight despite the
beating he takes early on in their clash
the yonko manages to shut luffy down for
good with just one shot of his thunder
barghua and let's not forget that kaido
is drunk at this moment while luffy's in
his fourth gear form again we can't help
but wonder if luffy has it in him at his
current strength to take down this
monster we're guessing that luffy will
need all the help he can get and perhaps
even a monumental power-up if he's to
defeat the commander of the beast
pirates
[Music]
claiming the third spot is a clash
between titans
the meeting between goldie roger and
whitebeard which comes during a
flashback scene in the wano arc is the
stuff of legend and that's all the
reason we need to place this power
showcase this high on our list that's
not to say the action disappoints though
far from it the conqueror's haki clash
that unfolds when the two pirate swords
clash is one for the books the joy and
excitement on the two men's faces speaks
volumes of their fierce rivalry and
mutual respect roger and whitebeard
might not be main characters in one
piece but they've always been
inspirational figures whose names have
been revered and repeated from the very
beginning of the series after all what
is the pirate king and the inspiration
for our main protagonist luffy while the
other is the only pirate who's come
close to matching the pirate king's
power and charisma when we finally see
the epic encounter close to a thousand
episodes into the series it's claps and
cheers all the way
another whitebeard moment makes the cut
at number two
[Music]
[Applause]
this time it's his masterclass against
the despicable akainu in the battle of
marineford this fight's very different
in tone and spirit from whitebeard's
previously mentioned encounter with
roger which was a celebration of a
legendary rival against the ruthless
marine who's just killed ace and is hell
bent on killing luffy as well whitebeard
is the embodiment of righteous anger
that ground-shattering moment when
whitebeard drills his fist into akainu's
face is easily the highlight of the
fight the magma using admiral deserves
every bit of the relentless punishment
that whitebeard hands out to him like a
vengeful god the elements of grief
sorrow and fury make this an epic
demonstration of power befitting of the
supreme power that is whitebeard that
the yonko is fighting for his family and
honor despite being fatally wounded
makes this one of the greatest clashes
in one piece his ultimate sacrifice at
the end of the battle makes him an
unforgettable character
[Music]
[Music]
and that brings us to number one where
kozuki odin's one hour ordeal in a vat
full of boiling oil is unmatched as far
as power demonstrations in anime go a
leading figure of the wanawak and the
catalyst for the events that are
currently unfolding oden is a celebrated
warrior and ruler of wano who's
wisecracking lazy and brashly
adventurous personality hides his
incredible courage heroism and loyalty
he's sentenced to the most painful of
death by kaido and orochi who've usurped
his kingdom in his absence but even as
he's being boiled to death odin is such
a powerful figure that he can save his
retainers by placing them on a wooden
plank and holding them aloft for the
entire torturous hour this incredible
feat earns him the undying devotion and
love of his people the respect of future
generations and even the open admiration
of his enemy kaido a glorious death the
likes that we've not seen odin's final
moments are a beautiful haiku that
speaks not of defeat and loss but of
unparalleled bravery and sacrifice
[Music]
and that brings us to the end of the
video which is your favorite showcase of
power in one piece did i miss any out
make sure you leave a comment i'd love
to hear from you about it before you go
press the like button if you enjoyed
watching the video and if you love anime
in one piece you can subscribe to vinnie
tube where you'll find many top 10
videos to pique your interest until the
next video see ya
[Music]